qui est le meurtrier voici la question
que les joueurs se posent avec ce cluedo
grandeur nature pour la mortelle saint
valentin c'est une nouvelle murder party
la 17e organisé par la compagnie des
tisseurs de songe aujourd'hui on ce
comédien qui joue les suspects une
cinquantaine d' indices qui sont
dissimulés dans l'espace de covile les
participants doivent trouver l'assassin
de valentin la faune pour lancer le jeu
un petit film avec la victime est
présentée aux joueurs qu'il organisait
donc une soirée à un speed dating pour
jean rochard d'amour et a visiblement là
il a reçu un appel avec d'une personne
un peu agressive
il le met en danger et
il ya quand même un peu quand même hein
et quelque chose un peu de catholiques
sur cette histoire là cette murder party
a demandé un mois et demi de préparation
et la participation de onze comédiens
amateurs et professionnels un vrai défi
narratif pour eux je m'intéresse au
speed dating et c'est dans ce cadre que
j'ai atterri ici donc je sais tu cupidon
et évidemment c'est une
c'était un bon moyen de me produire dans
les soirées speed dating pour observer
ce qui s'y passe mais malheureusement il
s'est produit un drame
nous nous avons les éléments qui de
notre vie mais nous n'avons pas plus
d'éléments que ça
les joueurs d en bulles dans l'espace de
covile il tente de résoudre le mystère
et interroge les protagonistes à
technique c'est bien écouter regarder un
regard bien trop bien cibler les bons
d'indicés après ça cent-quinze personnes
étaient présentes par session de jeu
deux heures dans quête de
rebondissements d'un trig à partir de 10
ans
[Musique]